[Music]
welcome back
to our third and final panel of the
spectators energy
summit sponsored by national grid we're
going to
and start asking some pretty difficult
questions about whether green technology
is really capable of meeting the demands
of our pretty energy intensive economy
after all many of the um or from
uk's most polluting sectors are crucial
to sustaining our everyday life
heat amounts to something like a third
of uk's greenhouse gas emissions
and most homes in the country still use
natural gas
for heating or for cooking it's going to
take some
switching to change people to different
form of heat
now if these household households don't
start using lower carbon sources
it's pretty unlikely that the 2015 net
zero target
is going to be met so from industry to
homeowners how does society shift
to green technology is it realistic to
expect them to do so
and can we really start to ban people
from putting in gas heaters and gas
ovens in their home now with a slight
change to the scheduled lineups lady
vermo won't be able to join us but
instead
we will be joined by dr nina skripska
who's
head of the renewable energy association
lord dempton who's chairman of the
climate change committee
and also by tony green at national
grid i'm going to ask all of our
panelists to have some opening remarks
then we'll enter some general discussion
and then finally we'll take some
questions from you
so if you can think of questions while
they're talking just email them via the
um zoom technology or send them to
events
at spectator dot co dodge uk
and we'll put your questions to the
panelists in a few moments but first
can i ask dr nina
to start us off
hello and and good morning yes very
interesting question that's been posed
can green technologies meet the demands
of an
energy-intensive society well i think if
we
look at power and the progress to date
we can
understand whether green technologies
can meet this
and it's been a success story for
electricity so far
i think many of people who already have
heard the sessions earlier
will be aware of some of the statistics
but let me rattle through a few for
power
so renewables already provide over 35 of
electricity demand every year
and this continues to increase and
indeed
the first quarter of this year we were
around about
47 up from 35.9
last year this time and if you are going
to
whether you believe um renewables can do
this alone
well we believe as from the the sector
that renewable care can surpass fossil
fuel generation
as soon as 2023 and then if you add
other low carbon technologies
that proportion rises to around 62.1
percent of this
compared to the previous year so if you
add a nuclear
and it's not a case of if green
technologies can meet our energy demands
they can but i believe it's how green
technologies can be supported to meet
that demand
so if we want to generate more you know
we need an extra 100 gigawatts to meet
that
2050 net zero carbon target that
national grid
with the overall energy demand climbing
so
how come this all been done well i think
everybody's aware
that technology prices for wind and
solar have come down
but there's so many more other
additional technologies
and as fraser mentioned earlier heat and
transport
and tackling our energy-intensive
businesses that sector will be the real
challenge going forward but if we can
learn from what's been done for power
and even if we overlook the stop start
policy cycles that we've seen over the
last decade
i i'm optimistic that we can deliver
that
but we won't just be renewable
technologies that
everybody's familiar with solar and wind
it's biomass power
biomass heat um anaerobic digestion how
we use
waste how we then look at how our homes
can play a role
as being little virtual power stations
as well as the opportunities
and i say opportunities for industry
to play their part but we do need a
whole alignment
of policies regulation
business rates taxation to really get
that
that whole process going and over this
last summer
just to find a final point we work very
closely
with the government particularly under
kovit 19
circumstances and like everybody else
i think everybody's put forward their
10-point plan
of how a green economic recovery can
really happen
as a pan sector in terms of power heat
transport and circular economy
we came forward with our ideas of how we
could move forward
and that's for the next 18 months two
years
but then we also have strong views of
what we need to be doing for the longer
term
of how we can deliver a system of carbon
capture and usage and storage
and also the green hydrogen agenda and
the pathways to it
so in show i think we can
so uh i'm looking forward to answering
anybody's questions
on the my new tie of the details of the
challenge of how we can do it
thanks fraser thank you nina well one of
the toughest knots to crack here is
transport of course say it's if it's not
politically
plausible to tax the poor off the roads
now to the sky you need to find better
ways of
finding um ways of moving people around
in a carbon efficient way
tony green national grid and let's hand
over to him
now tony many thanks fraser and thanks
everybody
um so yeah i am interested in the
decarbonisation of transport my focus is
is largely on hydrogen and it's wider
opportunities and
when we look at the the conversations
that have taken place on the previous
panels i think we're we're all in
violent agreement that um
tackling climate change is absolutely
crucial but the pressure is now on to
really deliver
if we if we look at some of the
challenges that uh lie ahead as we
we move towards net zero we've got to
focus on decarbonizing our homes
decarbonizing our vehicles and
decarbonizing heavy industries
as you said in your introduction um
about a third of the emissions
come from our homes that's 85 of homes
in the uk use gas currently
and the transport sector amounts for
around 27
of our emissions um if we were to
successfully decarbonize that pathway
we'd have to remove around 27 billion
liters of
diesel uh from the market today so
as the gas transmission owner across gb
and the electricity transmission owner
in england we recognize we've got a real
responsibility
in facilitating this shift we're
exploring
how we can use technologies such as
hydrogen and i will say in both its blue
and its green form as was mentioned
earlier
and carbon capture and usage to
decarbonize industry
buildings and and the heavy transport
space
and we're supporting on the
decarbonisation of a number of the
clusters that
the minister mentioned earlier on but in
order to
increase the reach to the whole country
we're also looking at how we repurpose
existing assets such as the gas
transmission network
to carry hydrogen as we believe this
will actually reduce
overall costs of a transition to net
zero and really open up opportunities to
look at energy as a whole system
particularly as we look at hydrogen as a
storage vector
for renewable electricity generation
and i think it really helps that we've
got this unique view across electricity
and gas
and it's um all of its connotations
um whether uh be blue or green
um and one of the things we've got to
really remember here is that we've got
to bring
consumers with us um the the energy
transition has got to be done
with people rather than two people and
some of our research that we've done
recently really illustrates that
people are really not aware of the the
nature of the energy transition
and the impact it's likely to have on
them and as we've spoken to them
it's it's become very apparent that we
need to really educate more people
as to what the needs are we need to look
at more in the way of energy efficiency
and work towards that whole net zero so
we've got a really exciting time ahead
there's an awful lot to do and we're
here to support that
great sony thanks very much indeed and
finally delighted to be joined now by
lord depton the chair of the climate
change committee well thank you very
much
and i'm sorry i couldn't come before but
i was busy doing exactly this with the
water industry
because this is a moment in which we're
i think making the best of what
could otherwise be a disadvantage and
talking
uh much more decisively about some of
the real issues that
with with which we're faced i can't help
but
picking up on anthony green's comment to
start with because
um it is absolutely true that the energy
industry has to take
the public with it but the difficulty is
that the public has a connection with
the energy industry which is largely
unsatisfactory
i mean if you look at any of the surveys
of customer satisfaction the connection
between the uh utilities that serve us
with our energy and the public
is terrible and i've often had to say
look we're not going to take the public
with us until
um and i'll be prank uh until endpower
answers the telephone
it it's a fundamental issue about how we
connect with um
our customers if we are going to try to
make these changes effective
and one of the things we have to do is
to connect the second thing we have to
do is
actually to speak in a language which
people
understand i've banned the expression
um kilowatt hour from uh
the climate change committee because i
don't believe anybody
really knows what a kilowatt hour is
outside
so unless you talk in terms of people's
bills unless you talk in terms of people
what people
know about you can't expect them to be
taking seriously what we're trying to
deal with um and that's because
we are all interested in this we're all
keen on this we are people who
who've spent our lives doing this but
we're dealing with the public which has
got us
lots of other things to do things that
they thinks are better to do
and so we have to find a formula for
reaching into those lives so that they
understand and realize insofar as they
need
to take their part in what is a national
and
international endeavor so
for me i start with the communication
element because i think otherwise we're
not going to
be able to answer some of the other
tough questions
questions which indeed fraser you've
put to us and so at one end it's
how do you get the mass of the public
to recognize the issues and to realize
why everything from energy efficiency to
some of the new techniques are going to
be
necessary at the other end we have to
ensure that the
difficult industries the ones which
really have a problem
uh very heavy users of energy
how they're going to overcome their
future and
uh overcome their problems in a way
which contributes to the future of all
of us
and i do find it difficult sometimes
people talk about some of these
industries as if there's something nasty
about them
if you want to make cement it does take
an awful lot of energy
the cement industry has to try to make
it less energy intensive
we need to find alternatives to cement
wherever that
is possible and wood is for example in
many cases going to be
much more widely used but in the end
we're going to have to have a cement
industry and if we're going to have to
have that then we've got to find an
energy
answer to that and it's a mixture
of the industry itself minimizing its
demand
and us discovering ways and you
mentioned
uh the issue of hydrogen that may be one
of the ways
ways in which the uh clusters of heavy
industry can be
can be satisfied in a
zero-carbon way that's why the climate
change committee has been so
tough about saying that carbon capture
storage and usage is
absolutely essential and why we do
think there has to be a day march in the
hydrogen direction even though we
don't necessarily know whether it can be
done
in the way which we hope it can be done
clearly at the moment
it's very expensive environmentally
to achieve what is supposed to be an
environmental answer
we've got to find ways of producing it
in a way which is not like that
but we can't ignore it we have to accept
that it is one of the possible ways
in which we can solve the real problems
that we have and again it's
not either or it's both and
one of the problems i think we have in
the whole of the energy industry
is that people get very enthusiastic
about their particular bit of the energy
industry
whereas what we really need to have is a
very much better and wider concept
where people are working uh all to uh
together
and and dealing with things as part of a
whole
and the last thing i want to say
is simply this climate change won't wait
we have a a
need to deliver on zero carbon by
net zero carbon by 2050
we can do that and we can do it in a
cost effective way
but we can only do that if we are
actually doing it
now and not tomorrow we are actually
carrying this through and there are a
whole series of
simple things which need to be done
and which the energy industry ought to
be very determined to insist on
we have to stop building houses that
have to be retrofitted
the government has now allowed a million
houses to be built
which have to be retrofitted because
their energy
demand is far too great we've really got
to stop infrastructure
projects which don't understand that
they have to contribute to net zero
rather than make it more difficult we
really do have to make
those decisions the government has at
the moment put out for example
a discussion on uh on planning changes
if you read those planning changes
carefully you'll see that
they don't take anything like the
required necessary steps
to deliver net zero by 2050
they are lacking in very fundamental
changes which are necessary and so when
we talk about the energy industry
we're talking about an industry which
will be relying
on all sorts of changes which need to be
made
elsewhere that doesn't mean to say that
it should
sit back and expect others to change it
needs to be
part of the campaigning mode to ensure
that the parameters
within which it has to work and develop
and expand are actually those that make
that development that work and that
expansion possible
john gomer lord devin thanks very much
and let's go now to audience m questions
all right tony first question from you
from adam little
um very interesting what you're saying
about hydrogen but isn't the truth that
we've just simply missed the boat
with hydrogen and given that the
industry is focusing on
electric vehicles this lots of
investments have been made
and the consumers have decided the
hydrogen has just simply come along too
late
to pick up in a significant way
i i think the answer to that is no
from a vehicle's perspective the
electric vehicles are very suited to the
smaller types of vehicles
but for heavy goods and particularly
passenger transport and as we move on
into
say maritime or aerospace
hydrogen presents a very different
option and a much better storage vector
batteries are very heavy
you move into heavy goods vehicles and
the performance is not so great so
we're looking at um the the options for
hydrogen in that space
and particularly green hydrogen the more
pure form of hydrogen feeds very very
well into that
and if we can actually start
distributing that
through our networks it starts to change
that entire vector
so you can fill up a hydrogen vehicle
in minutes in the same way as you can
fill up a car or a vehicle today
uh if we can distribute that hydrogen
around you'd be able to fill up your car
in a hydrogen way
in a very very similar fashion so i
don't from a transportation point of
view i think we're just seeing the start
of the decarbonization you've got
electric vehicles out there now i think
there is an opportunity for hydrogen to
still play a role in that space
but there's a much bigger role for
hydrogen in decarbonising industry for
decarbonizing heat as well so
i think transportation is a is an
additional piece
um but there's the more traditional
markets that we we've got that we can
decarbonize
as we go thank you julie a question now
for
nina skrupska it's um from nick you asks
do you think that heat pumps are the
answer to decarbonizing
heat in households we've seen quite a
lot of development in those
recently and some countries in
scandinavia they're everywhere
do you think this is going to be the
next big thing in british
energies domestic energy supply well if
you look at
the areas that the government have made
some positive
um statements of how what they want to
do to help decarbonize homes
heat pumps is one of the the important
technologies
and but then the the marrying of them
of with our existing housing stock
makes the decision to use them um a
little bit more tricky
and there are other forms of
decarbonizing
our housing stock obviously the first
one is um
the energy efficiency improvements is
lord lord david has mentioned
that all our homes should be made as
energy efficient as possible
and then once that's done then you
you'll find that heat pumps
whether air source or ground source
depending on
the type of um building uh housing
infrastructure that you're considering
then they
they play a very important role but for
some other areas
homes that are not connected to the gas
network as we see
um there are other solutions so like for
instance
biomass heating you know sustainable
good with a good air quality also
renewable and low and petroleum
gas it's not petroleum but renewable
gases
that can go in and displace oil heating
i think
as as we as um john had said earlier
it's not an either no we need all of
these ways
of transforming and decarbonizing
our homes because it is one of the
biggest challenges that we're going to
be facing for sure
electrification plays its important role
as well
so some homes with solar panels
very energy efficient energy storage
so that those prices are coming down so
it's not
as we previously thought if you only
heated a house
with electricity that this would be the
most expensive way of doing so
the whole of the understanding how we
can make our homes
energy efficient and affordable is
turned on its head
with the advent of these new
technologies okay
that's um john gomer lord devon a
question for you
from david kane um as an island an
obvious
source of green power for britain would
be the title
and wave generation something which your
committee doesn't seem to focus on very
much
is that because you just simply don't
think the technology is going to
be there or could this be a trick which
you're missing
well i hope we've not missed the trick
but i can't resist in saying that the
my air source heat pump goes in
on monday and our heating here will be
zero i hope when we replace lpg with
uh biogas um so i'm a total committed
uh person to heat bumps um and i
believe we can see very very much one if
as long as they're
used in a hybrid sense um and as long as
people
as long as we get as long as we get
simpler at explaining what they are
i come back to the point about making
making things accessible to everyone
how would you describe a heat pump then
i mean you're stopping your ground the
street
how would you persuade them to get a
heat pump well i would simply
say that if you if and ask you first of
all
how you heat your house now
that's central heating well then all you
need to do is to arrange
through one of the many companies that
will do this for you
to install a heat pump which will reduce
your
energy use and your costs
and keep you warmer if you do that
and there's no better argument that say
you will spend
less and the government helps you to
contribute to do that
by the hybrid as long as you do it in a
particular way
and so you'll be a few quids in over a
few years
and how long would you have to wait um
you'll be asked before you start to see
a net return on this well it depends
entirely upon upon your present
situation i know it's
difficult to say that but it it we are
talking about
a very much more limited amount of
outlay
and long-term savings and if you gave me
your details i would make sure you could
have an exact
quote for that purpose okay well
any questions to them here i'm sure you
can come around to your house anyway
like back to the question about tidal
power it is
you know perhaps we'll be talking about
this two years time well we're we look
at tidal power very carefully um
i i'm instinctively a believer in tidal
power it seems to be wonderful
you know when the tide is going to be
before i became
chairman of the climate change committee
i was involved in seeking to have
a uh a barrage in the seven which i
still believe to be
a really sensible way forward the
trouble is
at the moment no one has come up with a
cost-effective way of doing this
the government has been encouraged to
look at these
they haven't yet been able to see one in
which the
invest public investment seems to be
getting
the kind of return i have a problem with
this which is a personal problem
which is that i do think sometimes the
the financial mechanisms which we use
to measure some of these things seem to
me to be out
of date if you said to the average
father of a family if you were
if you spent a bit more on your
electricity now
your children could have free
electricity
they would be very likely to say yes
they wouldn't
say well i've got to apply a whole lot
of technical arrangements about
net costs and various things before i
could come to that conclusion
they instinctively think that uh
carbon that that um
that wave power uh and that uh barrages
ought to be a good answer and i still
believe that we could do a lot
more to overcome the
the uh financial reasons that have so
far
inhibited them okay
um tony green a question for you from
john
catermell um what do you
do where do you see the investment and
uptake of fuel cell technology
in homes as well as transport do you
think that's going to be much of a
factor in the next few years
i think it could be and i
i caveat my answer here because fuel
cells require very pure forms of
hydrogen if we are to
distribute hydrogen through our networks
the hydrogen by the time it arrives at a
property is likely to not be of the
quality that you need to drive a fuel
cell
so i believe um fuel cells will play a
role
um if you have access to the green forms
of
hydrogen which would come from
electrolysis so it probably
fuel cells within vehicles probably
suits fuel cells within sites where you
can actually get a delivery of green
hydrogen to it
but as regards fuel cells in the general
population that would be much more
challenging unless we can come up with
ways
of cleaning the hydrogen to the levels
that
are needed for a fuel cell or we make
them more robust
there's a lot of disruptive technology
going on in this area i was talking to a
company only the other week
that have developed a carbon level
filter that operates at the 40 pico
meter level which is
absolutely minute and they're getting
very very good levels of performance off
that so the opportunity for d
blending uh as i call it hydrogen from a
gas source
is starting to emerge and it could start
to get quite interesting but we need
that price point to come down
we need we need hydrogen into the
networks to to be able to uh to really
see that
so i think fuel cells have got an
opportunity
it's just how when and where the the
right quality of gas and the right price
point starts to emerge for us
another question for and john gummer
it's from
david francis and you seem to be quite
upset with the government's
behavior when it comes to the
regulations on new homes
do you think it's time to simply ban
putting
in gas central heating in new homes
well the government has committed itself
to making that illegal
from 2025 and that is certainly already
on the uh on the program
now what i what i feel very strongly
about
is that um the government at the time
reversed the decision to have net zero
homes which had been put into the
program
the industry with one or two notable
unacceptable exceptions the industry has
a whole
had prepared themselves for that and
then
the government backtracked so we've lost
that whole period of time
what we're waiting for now and we're
still waiting
is for changes in the um in the building
regulations
much tougher and higher demands
and also uh i believe that we should be
tying into uh the work that we're doing
in terms of investment
into housing in a post-covered world we
should be making
absolutely clear that none of that
investment
will be done in homes which do not meet
a level which is somewhat akin
i put it carefully to the passive house
system
which of course means to then give
people a home which costs
very very little to heat it's a very
important contribution
to to the reduction of poverty and fuel
poverty in the country
okay a question for nina from peter
cutts
what potential do you currently see in
domestic electricity
storage is that going to be something
we're going to be doing a lot more of
or is the technology simply not there
for us to do it to any significant
extent
well the technology the technology is
there now and
and the problem at the moment is
how do we make people aware and also how
do we tackle
matters like uh level leveling it up
with other forms of technology
it's such an exciting arena of
incorporating
domestic batteries and particularly when
some
of the suppliers are looking at
second-hand
second life uh electric vehicle
batteries so you see you start to see
this recycling
of components so at the moment for
instance
solar panels and um home
battery systems are charged at higher
vat rights
at rates than anything of fossil fuels
going into people's homes
so that's one example of how would you
would encourage
matters like that but at the same time
we've got to
also open up the markets so that
there are companies are coming up with
some fantastic
innovative business um models
who will act and pull together the
the generation or the battery storage or
if the
if homes will have in the future
electric vehicles
and we'll see vehicle-to-grid transfer
of power depending on the price
of the electricity you could see
people's homes being
an aggregation and creating virtual
power stations
so the all models of how we look
at the power market are being turned on
their head
in order for people whether they want to
be
actively nerd like like i am about my
home
and my solar panels through to the
people who don't want to know
anything about their electricity but can
trust companies
will help them make money from the
assets that they've invested in their
homes
that's the future we're moving to it's
about the choice
and being able to combine all of these
different opportunities together to
decarbonize our systems
so it's here now isn't it risk
it becomes a depreciating asset i mean i
don't know when you got your solar
panels installed you're probably an
early adopter were you
i installed mine in my well
i'll tell you where i live now i'm very
fortunate i live on the coast
and i've got an apartment in a big very
old creaky victorian house built in 1845
and i have insulated the beep
out of it so that my electricity because
i have no gas here
my solar panels essentially have reduced
my energy bill
to only 200 pounds a year and i've got a
three and a half thousand square foot
property
so i've i've done those steps over the
four years i'm not an early adopter from
2011 when feeding terrorists were very
high
but i've got the right balance so at the
moment
i'm looking at the next choices of how
you know the
tech because the things we've not talked
about is
um what has changed in the last 10 years
we've got all these wonderful renewable
technologies but it's
how they're combined and how they can
provide
that offering now into a modern
system and that's the steps that we need
to bring
people along with people love their
iphones and their ipads
you know all of this is going to be
visible on there i can look at my ipad
and select how each single room is set
up
just because of the clever thermostats
so this future we're going into
is not the building and infrastructure
that we've had in the past
we've got to be able to embrace and take
people with us
to understand what solar panels
batteries electric vehicles
heat pumps biomass boilers in areas
where it suits that building better
or biogas hydrogen all together
what is that future going forward so but
batteries are here now
they're not a thing of the future
they're here now right
but tony and this is another interesting
aspect people do love their iphones but
they tend to get a new iphone every
couple of years an expensive business if
you're trying to keep up with technology
if it changes all the time
improves all the time certainly you know
we're at an age of innovation
you can see country where somebody might
think okay i love the sound of nina's
victorian house
she pays 200 a year that's great let's
go down to her installer let's get it
under mine
but at the back of your head you might
be thinking well if i waited for a
couple of years i'd probably get
even cheaper and get even more energy
out of it so
isn't there a paradox that when
technology is moving you're talking
about hydrogen
on fuels and technology all kinds of
innovation the people are a little bit
worried about investing in something
that's going to get out of date
pretty quickly that's that's certainly a
risk um
technology is evolving um it's evolving
in the gas sector as
well though um baxie and worcester bosch
you've got hydrogen boilers now
um that are in their labs they're
they're running on up to 100 hydrogen
and they reckon by 2025 they could be at
market at volume and at scale
um so from the point of view if we're
not going to have hydrogen available in
the networks for a period of time
we could be in a situation where you
could buy a hydrogen ready boiler from
2025 onwards
and as we start to be able to put green
gas into the network
you can switch over to that so
technology is evolving very very quickly
we've got to go back to ultimately the
customer and the consumer as we started
in our conversation earlier
consumers are largely very ignorant as
to what what the options are at the
moment
they know what they want they want a
warm home
they want to be able to turn the cooker
on when the cooker comes on
um so we've got to help them work
through that process what they are
ultimately concerned about is the
upfront costs the impacts on their
ongoing bills as nina mentioned a moment
ago bills are obviously very very
important to them
so ultimately we as the industry and
government have got to help them work
through
how do we remove those upfront costs and
sort of de-risk
the whole situation for them i think in
investing in the whole energy efficiency
piece we've discussed
is is absolutely critical we've got to
reduce the amount of energy we use
and then the various technologies can
start
stepping in and it won't be one solution
for everybody
i don't i i'm not sitting here saying
hydrogen's the answer or heat pumps are
the answer district heating's the answer
i think we're going to see a mosaic of
solutions
we've got to utilize that whole systems
approach that nina mentioned earlier
there will be regional solutions that
will suit different
aspects of particularly our home stock
nina's home is a particular example i
live out in the in a rural community
it's a house built in the 1800s it's
very very hard to insulate
so i need a different solution to nina
if you're refitting a home
you can do an awful lot and a heat pump
is probably the most suitable
but actually if you've got a legacy home
with no wall insulation and so on
actually a hydrogen boiler might be the
best solution because you're more
limited
on what your options are and you can't
afford to rip your house apart to fit a
heat pump
that needs more efficient insulation and
more
radiators or underfloor heating to be
efficient
so i think it comes down to you know
we've got to keep an eye on the
technology going forward
and we've got to use the best solutions
going forward and cutting off one or the
other
doesn't necessarily help us we need to
keep the options open and do the best
job we can at the time of the technology
we've got
and some decisions we may have to come
back on in the future but
the key thing is we do something we've
got to be moving forward
there's 20 odd million homes out there
we've got to start work on that soon
because the problem's just going to get
bigger and bigger as we head towards
2050.
right um john gomer and now
you're you know you're eagerly awaiting
the arrival of your heat pump on monday
and next week
um but the thing is here that i don't
know if you've got another
both and tony and nina have got houses
built in the 1800s i'm not quite sure
when yours was built if you're you're in
1893
1843 seriously so just two years after
nina's
there we are yeah right
okay but but you guys are quite you know
enthusiastic adopters here but you can
see somebody
sitting at home thinking to themselves
well if i am going to fork out for this
shouldn't i wait for this this hydrogen
boiler tony's talking about maybe that's
going to be the answer maybe
heat pumps are going to be very um very
yesterday's technology and the problem
is not
people have usually got the budget to do
this once every sort of
15 years you know the old saying you
only fit double glazing once if it the
best
if you're only going to get new sorts of
um heating in
you want something that's going to last
five years maybe it's just moving too
fast and the government regulation you
talk about maybe that is also
struggling to keep up there are many
people right now in housing
across britain who've been told that
they're cladding but they brought to be
more energy efficient that cladding
is the wrong cladding going to have to
take it down because it doesn't meet the
regulations
they're going to have to pay lots of
money to get new clothing put up it's
bankrupting lots of people
for seems to the government just
technology and government regulations
seem to be changing
at such a massive pace right now
that anybody who does stand to put
significant amounts of money
in upgrading renewable energy to their
house
does stand to lose out simply by
having it rendered out well of course he
also stands to lose out if he doesn't
change
because the cost of not changing the
energy cost
as cash is very considerable
so let's not think this is a one-sided
issue
and it's exactly the same with the issue
of the laptop when the laptop came in
there were a lot of people who said oh
well
i won't buy a laptop now because the
next laptop is everything going to have
x y and z
and then they said they wouldn't buy
that one and some of those people ended
up with no laptop at all
i'm using a laptop which has worked
perfectly well for
really quite a number of years and i
don't um
but i had to make a decision at one
point i had to decide i needed a laptop
and i was going to take what i could get
there and if i didn't do that then i
would not be able to join in the
remarkable modern technology that we
have today so frasier of course it's a
perfectly reasonable argument to have
and most people do have this concern and
wish
well perhaps i'll leave it for a bit
because i may get something better
but uh we you
don't get anything for nothing and those
people who aren't
trying to do some of these things are
paying through the nose for their energy
and so what we're trying to do is to
make it easy for people
to make the simple small and not very
expensive steps
and then begin to say well perhaps i can
make the biggest ones
don't agree with anthony if i may say so
this is a house in which i haven't had
to tear out all the
old radiators and such like by having a
hybrid system with biogas you can in
fact
deliver this in a perfectly reasonable
way
but it isn't as good as one would do
in a new house with underfloor heating
and the rest of it
all i'm saying is every new house
can be built not more expensively
the money can any of the little bit of
extra
can easily come out of the land price
every new house could be built so that
people paid
practically nothing for their
electricity and
didn't make the emissions that they do
now all that needs to be done
there is that the government sets those
standards not
not standards which demand you do
particular things
outcome standards which say houses have
got to be
of this energy efficiency we did that
and looked the house builders in the
face and said
you know perfectly well you can do that
you've always known you can do it
you said you could do it back in 2019
so let's get on with it yeah
sorry you know sorry do you want to
i i really i really support what john is
saying
when i joined as chief exec of the rea
seven years ago and i came back from
living in the netherlands who
at that time i thought was five years
ahead of the uk
in terms of addressing all of these
uh leveling up that people could enjoy
renewable energies and energy efficient
homes and they went for it in a big way
you know with
heat networks involved and changing
how heat networks that heated the homes
that were previously
burning coal or gas they would move into
biomass or biogas
and i came to the uk and i thought
fantastic 2016 we're going to be going
to net zero homes it was 2016
and it got turned on its head and it's
been fraught that was still
battling that our homes which even more
today
are our castles during covid19 when we
want to feel
safe secure and warm should be
the most energy efficient our people and
in this country deserve it so the green
homes grant is great which we've just
heard announced and i'm sure the
minister mentioned it earlier
but it's again six months to install
energy efficiency 2 billion it's just
not going to happen
so we need some pragmatic views like
john has said
all house builders now should be
installing solar panels
so cheap as you're building a house get
them built heat pumps in
gas networks that are going to be
promising to deliver gas
green gas all of those things should be
built
in with that home three phase power
supplies
why doesn't the uk have this norm
three-phase power supplies
to the home so you can have a heat pump
ev
charging and also solar panels to manage
it
that's the kind of steps changes that we
need
the building sector to move forward on
to help
us who want to deliver the renewable
solutions
to marry all of that in our
infrastructure
sorry i had to get off my high horse
just then
i'll get on that should there are a
million
families in homes which the
government of the time a conservative
government had deprived
of decent heating at a decent price
by going back on their commitment and
that's
the issue and we cannot go on like this
because every house that is built today
with very few exceptions what happens is
that the house builder
hands on the cost of heating
to the house owner whereas the house
builder
should be reducing that cost of hip
heating
by building the house in a way which you
would find it built
in germany or in in the netherlands
and really uh talking about taking back
control the first thing we might take
back control of
is setting standards for our people
which are of the same level as those of
other northern european countries
instead of
way behind and not allowing
our house builders to create uh profits
which are based on uh sums of money
taken from customers because that's what
you're doing
you're giving customers a bill for the
rest of their lives
because you're not building properly
well tony and nina and john gummer from
your 19th century
um homes thank you very much for um
joining me today
and it's and thank you very much
national grid for sponsoring
our summit which is now at a close we're
going to be
having all of our discussions up on our
website you can watch them again
at any point on spectator tv
so we've covered so much ground today
and so much is moving i'm still not
quite
sure whether to get my own water pump um
like
john gummer or whether to completely get
my 200 pound to build solar panel thing
like
nina but i'm sure there are lots of
options
and lots of food for thought that we've
had in today's fascinating m conference
thank you to a panelist thank you to all
of our speakers today
and thank you once again to national
grid for sponsoring
our summit thank you goodbye